Hi all.
Today's objective is to showcase how we
are using machine learning models to
enhance the productivity and efficiency
of business operations teams working on
charter of accounts mapping.
Currently,
the fund and property transaction
accounting,
specifically the chart of accounts
mapping processes, are done manually,
which leads to errors and inefficiencies.
The objective of this project is to
streamline and enhance the efficiency of
fund and property transaction accounting,
specifically aimed at charter of accounts
mapping processes using AIML techniques,
reducing errors and improving
efficiencies while accelerating
standardization and reconciliation for
CBRE operations.
The scope of the application is to
implement a user friendly UI for business
operation teams to upload files and for
the mill model to predict mappings
between source and target accounting
codes automatically.
We are also doing a human in the loop
which provides an option for the team to
manually edit for optimization and
enabling the mill OPS for continuous
model upgrade as a function additional
data overtime.
We followed an iterative approach to
solve for the challenge.
As the initial first step,
we analyzed the data provided by the
business operations team and got
clarifications on the same.
For two to Step 4,
we evaluated multiple models and
approaches to determine which best suits
for effectively addressing the problem
statement.
Once the model and the outcome was
finalized,
we demonstrated the application to
selected operation team members to
experience the application and test the
same during the same timeline.
We also get the approach and solution
reviewed by the data science teams and
enterprise architect groups.
The UI is built on existing CBRE Data
Portal application.
The interface allows the user to upload
an Excel file containing the Source GL
and Source description columns.
Upon selecting the sheet where the input
data is kept,
user submits the Excel file for the model
to predict CBREI mapping and CBREI GL
NAME for all the rows in the uploaded
Excel and displays it for the user.
By clicking on Download Data,
users can see mapping created by the Mill
model.
The application allows the user to
download mapping files,
both GL and description files,
individually.
In addition to this,
the web application also allows to edit
the data if there is an appropriate GL
description which fits the mapping and
this feature allows human in the loop
intervention for better data quality to
downstream application.
Whenever user edits the data.
The same can be saved for future training
of the model.
The application is currently under
testing and is being tested by the
operations team.
We have set up the ML OPS for continuous
training of new data for model
improvements.
The newly created models will
automatically be deployed and users can
see the improvements in accuracy of the
predictions.
We are setting up governance models to
capture model performance and seek
suggestions from the business users for
continuous improvement.
Thanks for watching the demo video and
have a nice day.